the san diego padre lineup will be
taking on that big southpaw right there
sean manaya making his 22nd turn of the
season and he's going to do something
the second time that he's already done
once this season that's face
a team two times in a row did that back
in may against the angels pitch very
well both of those games and will look
to pitch another great outing against
the san diego padre team he did well
against last time around famous had
back-to-back games going all for four
and striking out three times in each of
those games very festive atmosphere
3-2 is out towards deep left center
field back towards the wall and that
ball is gone a home run for tommy pham
takes it over that high fence in left
center field and for fam his 12th of the
year
nine pitch at bat and fam gets the solo
home run padres lead it one to nothing
lead off home run to start the ball game
for tommy pham
machado a shot off mania
he scrambles after it flips to first
gets machado looks like machado
actually checking with mania to make
sure he's okay that was a line shot
sounded like it hurt oh that's that's
that dead
thud
i can promise you two weeks from now
that leg of shamania is gonna look like
he dipped it in a vat of ink it's going
to be black and blue all the way around
swinging a mist struck him out off speed
so tommy pham leads off the ball game of
the home run padres with an early one to
nothing lead flake snow on the hill for
the padres 28 year old left-hander
making his 20th start his career era
versus the a's is 5.31
canna runs and the balls hit into right
field of base hit
just out of the reacha hosper cannon's
going to go to third marte's gonna try
for second and he's in there with a
double
perfectly executed hit and run and then
marte with that great speed
stretches it into a double
swing and a foul tip held onto by nola
first strikeout for blake snow couldn't
have come at a better time two down a
two-strike approach and i know that's
not something we talk a lot about
and mania blew it right by him
fastball christian could not
catch up to it and that's the second
strikeout two down two on and jake
mariznick coming up 3-2 pitch
and a liner into right field a base hit
coming around from second is nola
he will score the throw is cut off and
the padres take a two-nothing lead
jake mariznick with an rbi single and
the padres take a two-nothing lead to
odafan
and a grounder up the middle into center
field from third base comes ha sunk him
he'll score mariznick's head into third
with a head first slide he's safe and
the padres lead it three to nothing
tommy pham drives in his second run of
the night on top three nothing and
looking for more
on the ground up the middle and diving
as anders gets up and his throw is late
runels score padres take a four nothing
lead jake mariznick in the back door
cronenworth beats it out and the padres
have scored three times in the inning
stay back here in the bottom of the
second inning
and the strike three call over the
inside edge there you go another
fastball second strikeout for blake
snell one down here in the second inning
this would be pitch 45 for snell
canna will bloop this to shallow right
incoming is myers to make the catch
tagging is harrison here comes the throw
play at the plate he'll be out at the
play he got him will myers guns him down
from right field so turns out to be a dp
that ends the bottom of the second
inning and out of the major jam
is snell
marty runs
throw
not in town another stolen base for
starling marte
27 stolen bases for marta tied most in
the majors 2-2 pitch to jed lowry
got him
lowry strikes out again
to the curveball that time and it's the
third k for snell two down
find a row do your thing
that one is ripped to left field and
that's gonna get down it's gonna bang
off the wall
ramon loriano digging for second and
he's going to make it as the throw sails
over the head of jay cronin
gloriano with a double
but still time loriana runs
throw to third not in time the running
a's this time it's ramon lauriano who
gets to third with one out so you said
it best dallas they see something in
snell and they're taking advantage of it
right down the middle and by him at 95
he strikes out chapman 4th k for schnell
two down that's exactly what i've been
seeing with matt chapman and the decline
of the numbers cannot catch up to the
fastball that's a four seamer right down
the middle
lined into left center field a base hit
that's going to roll up the alley to the
track and the wall
machado heads into second base with a
stand-up one-out double good gapper to
left-center
and that double is going to end the
night for sean manaya diola scara coming
in for the a's
three balls two strikes to nola
line to left field that's in for a hit
back towards the track and the wall
machado will score behind him meyers
trying to score the throw will be late
the padres get two more on top six
nothing
austin nola drives in a pair
one and two
swinging a miss elevates and strikes him
out five strikeouts for schnell one down
in the fifth inning
marte's got a double a single and a
stolen base
and that one is smoked to left and that
baby's gone
so that was loud marta eighth home run
of the year first with the a's well how
do you get a marty party started
with fireworks baby
goes around that time and strikes out
sixth strikeout for snell two down here
in the fifth inning
two two
and this is hit to right center field
back goes grisham it'll make the catch
shy of the warning track that ends the
inning so snell does get through five
at 6-1 san diego
faces loaded two down 2-2 pitch
lined into center field to base it
machado will score
hosmer being waved around the throw is
going to be
late
missed the tag and hosper goes back to
tag the play two more runs for the
padres and they take an 8-1 lead
guns 1-1 to elvis andrews
line to right center and grisham will
dive and make the play
the gold glove centerfielder trent
grisham laying it out in right center
what a catch out there by trent grisham
[Applause]
no two
stuck him out in the padres win
so diaz works his way around a lead-off
double and the padres come up big with
an 8-1 win in game one
you